so what's up is going on another just
was literally working two seconds ago
he's busy I have the magic touch upon
what did you do I do not work and I know
this is the BTS surprise guys I'm
Carmichael Carmichael isn't-isn't
is a computer CGI avatar that just
operates camera yes test I am talking I
am talking loud because I I just cut
myself off the dope you know this isn't
an advertisement but if anyone is sick
out there it feels like they have a
common cold
emergency vitamin packets literally save
lives I'll just follow your neon shoes
thanks here we go yes much better
that's right guys looking good good come
on the bottom stuff yep let's bring it
up side and set it down
blue clear this is the moving business
is like though you like move stuff for
like five seconds and you take it in ten
minute break move it like - here take a
break right here
lunch lunch lunch is right there
literally just got a burning with a
similar is it really one of set yeah
baby with his desk but all this art
Simon he doesn't work like it straight
it doesn't work
fix it sir menu stopped working I had to
restart the frickin computer
well I Microsoft let's sit down here
like what we can do it and then you get
to there and you don't quite get through
the door correctly and then it falls
great three into a gigabyte excited us
yep there you go
Sam broke a screen while you're on the
movie shoot so we're on the way to the
post house that's doing editing for the
movie to do our first spotting session I
guess now and the directors come in and
give notes on the Edit that's called
spotting so we're going to do spot all
the things that need notes and be like
yo edit it differently to which they
will hopefully go okay versus we don't
have the footage looking at a potential
release date in April sometime a lot of
work needs to happen between now and
then it's a little worrying how little
scheduling there has been for notes and
planning stuff and getting the edits
done your cortisol so ever late salts
not quite yeah so there's been a lot of
stuff we gotta sort out even on that end
so fine why are we eating with music and
BMX at the same time